bonsoir voici les titres de l'actualité
de ce 14 avril à la veille du scrutin
présidentiel en algérie ne reste plus
qu'un seul candidat monsieur bouteflika
les six autres ont décidé de se retirer
en dénonçant des fraudes nous serons en
direct d'alger avec thierry thulliez et
monsieur mouloud hamrouche anciens
premiers ministres l'un des six
candidats qui dénoncent la fraude au
kosovo on ne sait plus combien de
personnes sont déplacées ni où elle se
trouve selon le hr ou le temps reportage
inédit au kosovo de notre envoyé spécial
maryse burgot et puis à bruxelles
réunion du conseil européen le président
chirac fait une proposition et le
secrétaire général de l'onu kofi annan
pourrait reprendre l'initiative
nous en parlerons avec christian mary
mono c'est donc demain que les électeurs
algériens a été convoqué pour un premier
tour d'élection présidentielle
à la veille de ce scrutin six candidats
sur sept ont décidé de façon
spectaculaire de se retirer en dénonçant
des fraudes c'est le processus
démocratique qui semble remis en cause
désormais récit de cette journée avec
richard binet l'élection présidentielle
et l'allemand le conducteur de la
légitimité d'être en retard de ce
scrutin
ils sont presque tous là les six rivaux
de bouteflika le grand favori des
élections présidentielles considéré par
nombre d'algériens comme l'homme des
militaires cet après midi ils décident
est en bloc le retrait de la course à la
présidence et de ne pas reconnaître la
légitimité du scrutin
dès ce matin les six hommes armés de
taleb ibrahimi le candidat soutenu par
l'ex fils en tête avaient demandé une
audience d'urgence au président laminé
zéroual audience immédiatement rejeté
les six candidats entendait le
convaincre d'annuler pour fraude massive
les opérations de vote entamées dès
samedi à l'étranger dans les casernes et
dans le grand sud pour les nomades à
l'appui de leurs accusations
le porte-parole du force des du front
des forces socialistes le porte par le
porte parole haïdar med a brandi devant
les caméras des bulletins de vote
tamponnais par l'administration qui ne
devrait être disponible dans les bureaux
que demain le silence des radios des
télévisions d'état montre l'embarras du
président zeroual en reportant les
élections il admettrait implicitement
l'existence de fraudes en poursuivant le
processus il ne proposerait aux
algériens qu'un seul candidat
comme aux plus belles heures du
monopartisme en france les
ressortissants algériens pouvaient voter
depuis samedi le faisait peu
l'abstention était importante mais il
restait très à l'écouté de la campagne
électorale voici quelques-unes de leurs
réactions recueillies en fin d'après
midi en france après l annonce du
retrait de six candidats sur sept
reportages christophe kulikov ski
yannick a aussi et raymond schappler
ils continuent à voter sans savoir sans
savoir qu'il ne reste plus depuis une
heure qu'un seul candidat abdelaziz
bouteflika à la sortie de l'isoloir nous
leur apprenons la nouvelle
voilà c'est le cas ce n'est pas votée
j'ai parfois vous dire franchement je
sais pas quoi vous moi c'est malheureux
comment on est parti pour voter pour
espérer avoir une chance quoi pour le
peuple
je pourrais pas vous dire sur le
dans la paix les représentants des
candidats qui se sont retirés vient
aussi d'apprendre la nouvelle
le retirant des élections sociales
raison ben il se trouve que le résultat
était déjà très violent avancé que pour
le premier tour il allait faire passer
avec une fraude massive et donc on va
pas cautionner on veut pas cautionner
une telle et crédibiliser une telle
élection
la représentante du dernier candidat en
lice refuse de réagir à visage découvert
pour des raisons de sécurité dit elle je
suis très surprise on n'a rien reçu
comme information en fait et je pense
que l'objectif des parties était de
saboter les élections c'est une manière
de détourner le choix du peuple algérien
parce qu'il a déjà fait son choix
merci oui déjà à marseille aussi le vote
continue pour ceux qui ne savent pas
encore sûr à voter elle n'est ce pas je
voudrais un castrat de voter alors s'il
reste un candidat et qu'on n'a pas le
choix donc je suis pas que ces cercles
pourtant pour y des journalistes
algériens réfugié en france la démission
en bloc des six candidats est une preuve
d'union de l'opposition et même le signe
d'un renouveau politique
c'est le début de quelque chose qui me
donne envie d'espérer mais c'est une
crise
politique réelle mais derrière dernière
derrière le nuage de cette crise y un
coin ciel bleu qu'on pourrait appeler
démocratie mais je crois que ça restera
ça reste encore une longue patience mais
là on a une amorce réel comme on en a
jamais jusque là en france ce sont près
de 680 mille algériens qui étaient
appelés à voter
depuis samedi dernier en direct d'alger
monsieur mouloud hamrouche ancien
premier ministre où vous faites partie
de ces candidats qui ont renoncé au
dernier moment alors monsieur amrouche
pourquoi avoir attendu jusqu'au bout de
faire ce geste puisque apparemment tous
les jeux étaient faits c'est ce que
disent même vos militants écoutez nous
avons très bien depuis quelques semaines
déjà dès le départ on a tenté d'éclairer
le fait accompli ils vont organiser des
élections fermé nous avons réussi chaque
fois à déjouer ce piège et a bloqué
cette machine chaque fois que le pouvoir
a donné des indices d'une reculade
mais en réalité ce n'était que tactique
chaque fois ils l'embêtaient d'autres
méthodes l'autre un mécanisme il vient
de le prouver
hier en interdisant le représentant de
suivre les violons itinérant il
m'appelle disons nous représentons
d'accéder aux bureaux de vote spéciaux
le ciel rouge souhaite je le rappelais
aux téléspectateurs français ancien
premier ministre d'algérie vous
connaissez bien les arcanes du pouvoir
donc vous n'êtes pas surpris par ces
fraudes
le problème c'est pas d'être surpris ou
pas
la question qui se pose aujourd'hui en
algérie su se dit ni flagrant de
reconnaître aux algériens le droit de
choisir leur président et de choisir
l'heure le programme qui leur convient
c'est ça la question qui se pose
aujourd'hui elle est plus grave elle est
plus importante que la fraude elle même
pourtant technique
monsieur bouteflika le seul candidat en
lice doit-il se retirer aucune idée le
fait que pour nous il n'ya plus
d'élections à partir du moment où les
candidats qui étaient en lice qui
étaient en compétition ont décidé de se
libérer de cette constitution il ya plus
de compétition donc pour nous rappeler
d'élections est-ce que la pire position
pour un homme politique comme vous ce
n'est pas justement de laisser la chaise
vide de se retirer de ne pas combattre
jusqu'au bout position haute
aujourd'hui c'est de trahir ce mouvement
fort qui vient de se créer à travers le
territoire national de paie trois ou
quatre semaines qui revendique avec
force un changement radical dans le pays
un changement du système de pouvoir un
peu plus de pouvoir des citoyens sur le
compte le contrat pour le contrôle du
pouvoir ils sont l'exercice
paradoxalement est ce que cette décision
de retrait ne va pas précipiter peut
être un peu plus de démocratie ne va pas
fait réfléchir et le pouvoir et la
population
de mon point de vue c'est un progrès
énorme
aujourd'hui les algériens et les
algériennes y sont avertis des
intentions du pouvoir une fois de plus
on vient de découvrir que les
engagements du président de la
république et du chef d'état major de
l'armée ne signifie absolument rien dans
un pays qui on dirige depuis plus de
sept ans et aujourd'hui la population
est avertie elle sait à quoi s'en tenir
souhaitez vous que ce soir le président
zeroual qui devait intervenir dans une
ère annuler les élections de demain
en tout état de cause sa responsabilité
race totale et entière quel que soit le
centre d'élaboration des décisions des
autres institutions
il reste le seul apte à prononcer ces
décisions est la meilleure des choses à
faire aujourd'hui c'est de reporter ces
élections au plus tard
mais s'il y à d'autres élections quelles
sont les garanties que vous demanderez
pour que celle ci soit réellement
démocratique qu'on demandera d'autres
garanties dont nous on proposera
d'autres mécanismes de contrôle pour
pour permettre à notre population de
s'exprimer librement et choisir
librement son président merci monsieur
mouche vous étiez en direct d'alger ce
qui vient de se passer en algérie
rappelle toutes les difficultés de la
mise en place d'une véritable démocratie
on se souvient de l'intervention de
l'armée alors que les représentants
islamique du fils était en train de
l'emporter dans les urnes rappel et
explications avec bernard lebrun sur le
banc des accusés aujourd'hui commis
l'armée est l'ensemble des corps
constitués de l'état placé sous le
contrôle des généraux seule véritable
dirigeant du pays comme le veut la
tradition les militaires va toujours les
premiers deux jours avant le scrutin
et dans le contexte actuel cela aura
suffi pour que les soupçons de fraude et
de bourrage des urnes gagne l'opposition
l'armée dans les rues d'alger l'armée
qui ouvre le feu contre les militants du
fils aux pieds de la casbah
c'était en janvier 1992 déjà le
processus électoral lancée par le trait
réformateur chadli bendjedid aller
s'interrompt
raison invoquée par les militaires
l'inacceptable succès dès le premier
tour du front islamique du salut +2 47%
des voix
l'état d'urgence est proclamé et un haut
comité d'état dirige le pays à sa tête
est placé mohamed boudia 72 ans mais ce
dernier est assassiné par l'un de ses
gardes du corps cinq mois plus tard
l'algérie plonge alors dans des années
de haine et de massacres ancien général
et ministre de la défense
liamine zeroual prend le pouvoir en
janvier 1994 ne sera élu président qu'en
novembre 1995 après avoir tenté en vain
d'ouvrir le dialogue avec le front
islamique du salut
il soutient le clan des éradicateurs
l'ale militaire du fils l'armée
islamique du salut pluie les gia
répandre la terreur dans l'algérois et
la mitidja en massacrant les villageois
isolés bentalha en 1997 relizane en 1998
village martyr une guerre civile qui
selon les sources fera de 70000 à cent
mille morts essentiellement parmi les
populations rurales enfermés dans leur
caserne pendant les premiers massacres
les forces armées sortent enfin sur le
terrain pour mener de véritables assaut
contre les maquis islamistes
la parole est aux urnes durant l'été
1997 liamine zeroual choisi l'apaisement
qui perd 1 bassi madani et organise des
premières élections législatives depuis
1980 où le vieux fln s'est mutée en rnd
et ce rassemblement national
démocratique véritable parti
présidentiel en portent évidemment la
victoire
la déception est immense mais partis
d'opposition protestent en vain pendant
des semaines contre la fraude électorale
alors qu'en liamine zeroual le 11
septembre 1998 annonce par surprise sa
démission et de nouvelles élections
présidentielles anticipées
tous les candidats de l'opposition
réunis des socialistes aux islamistes
prévient premier constat de fraude
ils se retireront aujourd'hui ils ont
tenu parole
thierry thuillier quid du processus
électoral maintenant à alger et quid
aussi peut-être de la démocratie vous le
savez en fait ce soir c'est une
situation politiquement totalement
inédite puisque en fait on peut penser
qu'il y a un problème juridique qui se
pose à savoir qui peut décider
aujourd'hui de l'annulation voire du
report du scrutin
mais en fait ici tous les observateurs à
alger estime qu en fait le problème est
entre les mains du seul liamine zeroual
le président de la république qui doit
s'exprimer dans un peu moins d'une heure
et son allocution est évidemment très
attendu
tous les scénarios sont possibles y
compris en fait celui de la poursuite du
processus électoral
demain les bureaux de vote pourraient
ouvrir à alger dans tout le pays
effectivement avec pourrait y avoir sept
bulletins de vote avec en réalité un
seul candidat présent abelaziz
bouteflika avec les seuls observateurs
de ce candidat
et vous imaginez bien évidemment le
résultat ce sera une élection à un tour
une élection évidemment facile mais
totalement discrédité en fait et c'est
évidemment une période de totale
incertitude qui s'ouvre et on pense tout
de suite à la situation dès décembre 91
lorsque entre les deux tours il ya eu
une interruption du processus électoral
par intervention de l'armée
merci thierry l'actualité du kosovo
c'est d'abord cette impossibilité
reconnue aujourd'hui par les
représentants de
autant comme ceux du haut commissariat
aux réfugiés de savoir très précisément
où se trouvent les réfugiés et combien
sont ils à l'intérieur de la province du
kosovo
une équipe de france 2 avec maryse
burgot gilles jacquier fabien bryant a
pu se rendre pendant plus de deux jours
à l'intérieur des frontières du kosovo
voici leurs reportages leur rencontre de
villageois déplacés dans des conditions
terribles mais aussi de militants
séparatistes de l'ofce cas ils sont
presque arrivés ces dames et viennent de
marché pendant plus de trois jours
nous avons entrepris de remonter ce long
chemin qu'ils viennent d'emprunter e
aristo monténégro nous nous nous
dirigeons vers le kosovo
au début le chemin est assez praticable
puis c'est la moyenne montagne
les heures passent les colonnes d'hommes
de femmes et d'enfants
avant ce temps silence ou presse
à eau
on ne se plaint pas beaucoup chacun
c'est d'ici qu'il n'y a pas d'autre
choix que d' avancée majeure n'est mort
de fatigue
on peut même pas s'arrêter pour dormir
on a traversé tout on attendrait moi
j'en veux plus
ils marchent parfois par petits groupes
chaque famille avance en forçant l'autre
car ils n'ont abandonné personne
ceux qui ne peuvent pas marcher sont
aussi de cet incroyable voyage
nous sommes maintenant au kosovo
beaucoup d'albanais effrayé par le
chemin qu'il faut prendre pour atteindre
le monténégro ont décidé de s'installer
dans les montagnes des campements
sauvages par centaines ou la vie
s'organise la guerre est à moins de
trois kilomètres à vol d'oiseau mais les
enfants l'ont déjà tout oublié des
adultes eux se font beaucoup de soucis
pour les jours à venir
nous on n'a rien fait à ce niveau bien
du peuple je pars tu mangeais pas du
tout des beaucoup d enfants et à maladie
à tous du dos et 100 cloud drive comme
ça du sommet des montagnes nous
apercevons les premiers villages me marc
départ les fermes les albanais en fuite
regarde de loin leur vie sans fumée cet
homme énumère les noms des villages
aujourd'hui en flammes
tu mens pas que tout
pour descendre vers la plaine il faut
courir pour éviter les snipers serbe
embusqués dans les montagnes qui selon
des témoignages recoupés tirs sur les
réfugiés viable un médecin un village
tenu par les hommes de lucescu les
combattants mais aussi les sympathisants
passent leurs soirées à étudier l'état
des forces sur le terrain
le moral n'est pas vraiment bon les
serbes sont en train de prendre village
après village toute la région ouest du
kosovo lendemain matin dans cette ferme
un vieillard est en larmes il un plan
qu'on ne l'oublient pas lorsque les
serbes arrivé deux heures plus tard les
prémonitions du vieil homme se vérifie
les serbes viennent de lancer une large
offensive ils seront taillables annica
dans moins d'une heure nous quittons le
village avec les derniers habitants
les paysans relâche tout leur bétail
la plupart des familles ont rempli des
charrettes pour essayer de sauver ce qui
leur appartient
mais comme des milliers d'autres ils
laisseront tout en chemin
cette jeune femme explique qu'elle reste
elle ne veut pas aller dans la forêt
hommes les femmes et les enfants de lier
bleynie de ça suit les bombardements et
débutent leur voyage vers le monténégro
en route ils rêvent les jeunes
combattants de lucetta même qu'ils ont
du mal à l'avouer c'est un doux chant
que j'allais bien l'an derni ils disent
n'avoir plus de munitions plus assez de
vivre
l'armée de libération du kosovo est en
train de perdre l'ouest du pays par
reconnaître que ces territoires sont
perdus tout ça c'est recul pour
l'instant pour protéger aussi sur le
chemin du retour notre téléphone
satellite par une attaque quelques
réfugiés installés dans des campements
de parler à leur famille en europe
plus tard il y aura à nouveau la neige
le brouillard et le cas à 19 heures hier
soir les gens étaient encore en pleine
montagne
ils ont certainement passé la nuit sans
abri et le plus souvent sans nourriture
ils arriveront demain commenté maryse
burgot pour nous adresser ce reportage
est retourné au monténégro vous êtes à
pabu reach à ce soir avec gilles
jacquier fait bien brillant vous venez
de montrer ce qui se passe dans les
montagnes du du kosovo
quelle est la situation autant que vous
ayez pu l'apprendre de l'ensemble des
réfugiés dont on ne sait pas très bien
le nombre d'ailleurs actuellement vient
écouter d'après des chiffres que nous
avons eu aujourd'hui il y aurait en ce
moment 18000 albanais dans la montagne
entre le kosovo et le monténégro 18
milles c'est un tiers de la population
de l'ouest du kosovo
comme vous l'avez vu ces gens sont dans
une usine dans une situation extrêmement
difficile les associations humanitaires
ne sont évidemment pas au kosovo
elles le seront peut être un jour mais
certainement pas pour l'instant
et vous savez lorsque ces gens arrivent
au monténégro leur situation est encore
assez difficile puisque nous sommes ici
à l'intérieur de la fédération
yougoslave
et c'est pour cela que les associations
humanitaires sont ici assez peu
nombreuses en tout cas si l'on comparé à
la situation en macédoine ou en albanie
ce que je voudrais vous dire aussi c'est
que lorsque l'on arrive au kosovo on a
l'impression d'assister à une tout autre
guerre pas celle que livre l'otan tous
les jours avec ses bombardements sur la
serbie non une autre guerre cette fois
sur le terrain au sol avec des
combattants de loups checa qui se bat
contre les serbes mais qui visiblement
n'y arrive pas vraiment en tout cas
c'est celle que c'est ce que nous avons
pu voir dans l'ouest du pays il est
évident que les troupes serbes avance de
plus en plus dans l'ouest du kosovo
maryse du running scène dans votre
reportage qui est tout à fait tc sète
cette femme qui décide de rester dans sa
maison
beaucoup tentent de rester malgré la
peur qu'ils ont de l'armée serbe
non non nous n'avons nous n'avons
lorsque nous avons quitté le village il
était véritablement désert les choses se
sont passées très vite donc on n'a pas
eu le temps de comprendre vraiment
pourquoi cette femme restait en tous cas
c'est clair qu'elle restait mais la
plupart des gens partent les villages
sont véritablement dr il n'y a pas
d'autre solution pour ces gens que que
de partir merci maryse pour l'aspect
diplomatique et la relance d'éventuelles
discussions et négociations des
européens étaient réunis aujourd'hui à
bruxelles il avait confié monsieur kofi
annan le secrétaire général de l'onu
montrant ainsi leur volonté de
réintroduire des nations unies dans
toutes les actions diplomatiques futur
alors question marie mono pour l'instant
est ce que vous avez pu faire un premier
bilan de cette réunion du conseil
européen notamment il avait un plan
allemand de paix possible tout à fait
claude l'allemagne création comme vous
le savez la présidence de l'union
européenne a donc pris une initiative
diplomatique et en présence qu'on vous
l'avez souligné qu'ils seraient tard
général des nations unies kofi annan
c'est la première fois qu'un secrétaire
général des nations-unies assista
conseil européen exceptionnel
la proposition allemande tient en trois
points trois points le premier tout
d'abord c'est le retrait des forces
serbes du kosovo second point la mise en
place d'une force internationale
troisième point enfin l'installation
d'une administration provisoire
cette initiative diplomatique européenne
la première du genre est pour le moins
originale devrait être soumise à kofi
annan qui devrait la proposer aux russes
la france de son côté a souhaité que
cette administration provisoire soit
sous l'autorité de l'union européenne
car après tout a rappelé le président
jacques chirac le kosovo se situent en
europe au sud est de l'europe nous parle
moi des balkans mu sud est de l'europe
et le président chirac à rappeler deux
choses essentielles
l'union européenne fera preuve de
détermination car il est nécessaire
qu'au force de l'otan'' s'ajoutent
initiative diplomatique aux dirigeants
serbes d'en tirer les leçons
merci question mariniers en marge de ce
conseil européen 10 premiers ministres
socialistes et sociaux démocrates
actuellement donc au pouvoir se sont
réunis jeudi c'est d'essayer de trouver
une base commune entre socialistes
les essais de règlement du conflit au
kosovo parmi les participants vous
l'avez vu ou outre monsieur hollande
monsieur j'ose pas tony blair et gerhard
schröder mais aussi le premier ministre
grec se soucie mutis ça ce monsieur
d'alema la grèce fait plutôt bande à
part actuellement face à l'engagement de
l'alliance qu'un faux slobodan milosevic
pendant ces débats la guerre continue
l'aviation des pays de l'otan a frappé
plusieurs cibles dont un convoi selon le
gouvernement serbe il s'agirait d'un
convoi de réfugiés et il y aurait de
nombreuses victimes dues au bombardement
de l'otan pour l'instant à l'otan ont
dit qu'on enquête sur cette frappe ce
bombardement ce raid d'aviation contre
des réfugiés donc selon les serbes selon
les serbes toujours il y aurait au moins
75 personnes de mortes dans ces
bombardements
aujourd'hui ce que vos ennemis l'eau de
vie de chat belgrade s'est déclaré
favorable à des observateurs civils au
kosovo il a fait une petite sortie
publique commentaires françois cornet
alors que la guerre contre la
yougoslavie entre dans sa quatrième
semaine sous un flot de critiques
slobodan milosevic est toujours
politiquement debout il a accueilli
aujourd'hui avec un pass exceptionnel le
président bélarusse alexandre
loukachenko
cette cérémonie a marqué la première
apparition du président yougoslave de
mon la presse internationale depuis le
début des frappes de l'otan
on sait que la yougoslavie a décidé
avant-hier par un bot de son parlement
d'adhérer à l'union qui lie la russie et
la biélorusse alexandre loukachenko a
déclaré que le président yougoslave
étaient d'accord pour la présence
d'observateurs au kosovo mais
exclusivement civil et qui ne viennent
pas des pays membres de l'otan
pendant ce temps les bombardiers
décoller de leur base pour la poursuite
de leurs frappes sur le causse goût et
l'on apprenait en effectivement en fin
d'après midi de source serbe que les
avions de l'alliance pourrait attaquer
aujourd'hui par erreur un convoi de
camions et de tracteurs de réfugiés près
du village de mai à août kosovo à cinq
kilomètres de la frontière albanaise
faisant 75 morts et 25 blessés à
bruxelles l'état major de l'otan dans
son briefing de l'après midi n'a ni
confirmé ni démenti
l' agence reuter confirme l de source
militaire alliée qu'un raid a bien été
menée au kosovo mai contre un convoi
militaire serbe et que l'enregistrement
de cette attaque serait analysé
dès le retour des avions en attendant à
washington on écarte qui traitent des
bombardements qui ont à nouveau touché
la nuit dernière ce complexe industriel
à une centaine de kilomètres de belgrade
et d'autres cibles en yougoslavie comme
des ponts ou des centrales électriques
pour les états unis tant que belgrade
n'aura pas cédé les reds doivent se
poursuivre et on réponse à cette
détermination américaine slobodan
milosevic 6 à 2 déclaré ce soir à
belgrade que les problèmes du kosovo ges
issues doivent tous résolus par ses
propres habitants et non par une
quelconque solution imposée de
l'extérieur après trois semaines
d'intervention militaire quotidienne des
forces de l'otan pour cette constat est
de constater que le but recherché par
les pays membres de l'alliance est très
loin d'être atteint
certes depuis le début du conflit les
porte parole de l'alliance ont répété
qu'il faudrait du temps des semaines
peut être des mois redit certains pour
réduire la capacité militaire serbe mais
la stratégie ou les stratégies suivies
par l'otan suscite bien des
interrogations commentaires leurs
embouts si c'était il ya quelques jours
en plein centre du kosovo
des dizaines de chars serm manoeuvrait
devant un général apparemment sur le
losc propagande ou fanfaronnade d'une
armée yougoslave bombardés
quotidiennement sur les avions de l'otan
ces images sont évidemment fait le tour
du monde des images gênantes pour
l'alliance atlantique qui avait fait de
l'affaiblissement de l'armée serbe au
kosovo un de ses axes stratégiques
aujourd'hui après trois semaines de
frappes 6000 sorties d'avions de combat
150 l'objectif totalement ou
partiellement détruits le potentiel
industriel et économique de la serbie
est très durement touchée mais le
président milosevic semble plus
intransigeants que jamais et l'armée
yougoslave moins affaibli que prévu
les forces terrestres serbes au kosovo
reste importante et reste menaçante et
je pense que si nous avons ces
mouvements de réfugiés que nous
évoquions tout à l'heure c'est bien
parce qu'il ya la poursuite de l'action
militaire qui sont qui sont menaçantes
pour le général clark le grand patron
militaire de l'otan qui a demandé le
renfort de 300 avions de combat il y
aurait même aujourd'hui davantage de
force haussière du kosovo qu'au début de
l'opération
une affirmation qui n'étonne pas les
experts russes
dès le début il était clair que dans les
airs et yougoslaves ne pourrait rien
opposé forces de l'otan quand on frappe
sur leurs centres de communication et de
commandement
on peut voir maintenant que ça n'a pas
une influence sérieuse sur les capacités
de l'armée yougoslave d'agir au kosovo
et même d'attaquer d'albanie alors
mauvaise stratégie mauvaise météo
mauvaise évaluation des capacités de
résistance de l'armée serbe ou
impatiente devant ces images de réfugiés
chassés du kosovo depuis quelques jours
les critiques pleuvent sur l'otan je
pense qu'ils ont débuté avec trop
d'avions il aurait dû attaquer beaucoup
plus fort maintenant il veut remédier à
cela mais ça va prendre du temps
au premier jour ils pensaient que ce
serait rapide et ce n'est pas le cas ils
savent que ce serait long campagne de
toute façon je crois que l'otan est
impliqué dans cette affaire
pour plusieurs mois peut-être même un
certain de sa victoire finale l'otan n'a
officiellement aucune stratégie de
rechange
les renforts aériens demandé par le
général clark vont permettre de
multiplier les raids et les frappes
à moscou le président eltsine a désigné
son ancien premier ministre monsieur
victor tchernomirdine comme représentant
spécial pour la yougoslavie s'est
peut-être l'annnonce du déclin pour
l'actuel premier ministre
evgueni primakov et puis aux etats unis
le président clinton qui intervient
régulièrement pour expliquer
l'engagement américain au kosovo à son
opinion publique
intervention encore ce soir où il est
dit que les bombardements continueront
tant que belgrade ne cédera pas dit le
porte-parole de la maison blanche
monsieur clinton a demandé une rallonge
budgétaire urgente et puis le pentagone
prévoit donc des renforts en avion et en
personnels militaires réservistes
correspondance philippe gassot avec
ariel mélange washington a décidé de
passer à l'étape supérieure en utilisant
comme pivot le porte-avions roosevelt
appuyé par un bâtiment français et
britannique du même type
les états unis vont encore mobiliser des
appareils l'otan réclame 300
supplémentaires
ce sont les américains qui en fourniront
le plus grand nombre pour soutenir
l'effort de guerre le pentagone pourrait
bien rappeler des réservistes
ces hommes et femmes qui participent
régulièrement à des entraînements
un week-end par mois et deux semaines
par an les états unis manquerait
notamment deux pilotes d'avions
ravitailleurs
tout cela coûte cher si l'on en croit
trent lott le chef de la majorité
républicaine au sénat
le conflit représente de 70 à 100
millions de dollars par jour 600
millions de francs
le président en recevant la maison
blanche les principaux dirigeants
politiques à l'intention de demander au
sénat des crédits d'urgence
l'effort américain accentue et sera
encore plus de demain avec nos alliés
nous sommes unis est d'accord sur ce
point nous devons rester sur la même
ligne et continuer jusqu'à la victoire
le congrès soutient traditionnellement
ses boys quand ils sont engagés dans un
conflit
bill clinton ne devrait avoir aucun
problème pour débloquer les crédits
nécessaires mais il sait qu'il ne doit
pas faiblir dans sa partie de bras de
fer face à slobodan milosevic
les américains déjà en campagne
présidentielle ne lui pardonnerait pas
alors avant de nous rendre en macédoine
et en albanie rejoignent nos envoyés
spéciaux dans les camps de réfugiés
voici visuellement reconstitué par
images satellites les conditions
géographiques dans lesquelles se
trouvent ces centaines de milliers de
personnes à partir de l'albanie et de
cook et vous allez voir les frontières
suivent plusieurs zones montagneuses
avec des pics situé pour certains entre
2000 et 2007 100 mètres d'altitude ce
qui explique les difficultés rencontrées
par les réfugiés sommes donc là en
albanie nous suivons la frontière en
haut de votre écran c'est le kosovo et
nous passons un coût cash
et puis ensuite nous allons rejoindre la
macédoine en macédoine en aperçoit assez
vite la vallée de skopje la capitale
avec la rivière vardar et un peu plus
haut à l'est le camp de blatche et où
sont arrivés plusieurs milliers de
réfugiés qu'ils ont franchi la frontière
la nuit dernière entre deux et cinq
militants mais l'armée macédonienne
bloquerait actuellement un millier de
réfugiés actuellement à cette frontière
des réfugiés qui sont soit à pied sur
quelques fois avec des moyens de
transport comme des tracteurs
voilà pour la compréhension du terrain
et de cette zone frontalière à
couquèques en albanie nos envoyés
spéciaux à dont sydney est philippe
chasselas ont écouté des familles qui
ont parfois échapper à des situations
dramatiques mais les témoignages de
femmes albanaise du kosovo confirme les
viols la barrière se lève du côté
yougoslave
c'est à peu près le plan thiam créateur
aujourd'hui encore le no man's land à
franchir et nous leur faisons les
premières questions d'où venez vous
quand êtes vous parti qu'est ce qui se
passe là bas
aujourd'hui ils étaient nombreux à
répondre en pleurant parce que leur
exode a été particulièrement du
ce sont eux qui ont été refoulés dans la
région de prizren la semaine dernière
sur la route de la frontière et dont on
était sans nouvelles il raconte qu'il y
en a encore des milliers derrière eux à
pied pendant une semaine ils ont été
emprisonnés successivement dans deux
écoles par les cernes à la première
école lisant amener les avions de l'otan
a survolé l'armée serbe a commencé à
leur tirer dessus
dix minutes après nous ont attaqués qui
a attaqué l'otan a attaqué la base
d'herbes et nous on était au milieu de
la deuxième école on était six cents
personnes
ça allait bien qu'on sorte pour faire un
peu de lavage alors il nous tirer de
l'argent ils tiraient dans les visions
on était obligé de se coucher par terre
dans ce groupe
les tirs ont fait au moins un mort un
jeune garçon de 12 ans tué dans la cour
de l'école
mais le convoi comportait d'autres
blessés six au total dont deux ont été
évacués vers tir amenant leur
plaignaient de trois jours commençaient
à s'infecter
ce garçon qui n'appartient apparemment
pas au groupe de l'école affirme avoir
échappé au serbe en se sauvant dans la
forêt ils ont tué mes cousins ils ont
tué mon beau père mon père était là il a
réussi à s'échapper
enfin parmi les réfugiés arrivés cet
après midi certains viennent de la ville
de prizren selon eux des albanais du
kosovo sont employés par les serbes pour
creuser la route en vue de la mine et en
macédoine dans le camp de stankovic sont
les personnels de l'eau et son
organisation pour la sécurité et la
coopération en europe qui ont pris le
relais des membres du haut commissariat
aux réfugiés plutôt déficient
ce sont eux qui gèrent les préparations
départ vers les pays choisis par les
réfugiés ces derniers n'ont plus de
papier les militaires serbes ont voulu
ainsi concrétiser leurs propos aux
kosovars qu'ils excluent s'il jette à
chaque fois vous ne reviendrez jamais
reportage valérie fournier frédéric
basket
un peu d'encre sur la main en guise de
passeport cet homme est le numéro 154 à
destination de l'allemagne
ce marquage et la solution trouvée par
les troupes allemandes de l'alliance
pour identifier les candidats au départ
des réfugiés qui n'ont souvent plus de
papiers d'identité
les serbes sont venus chez nous au
sortir de la maison
ils ont menacé de me tuer si on
obéissait pas ils ont pris nos papiers
d'identité
les ont déchiré et nous on dit
maintenant on ne pourrait plus revenir
au sauvons nous évacuent tellement vite
qu'on n'a rien pu prendre
lino papier ni notre argent nos droits
on est parti leur identité a été
recueillie de vive voix par les
observateurs de l'osce et des
observateurs qui ont choisi de passer à
l'action
lorsque le hr n'était pas présent pour
enregistrer à leur place tous les
réfugiés qui entrait dans les camps il
est évident qu'ici au kosovo il ya eu un
problème de nerf
je ne vais très certainement pas la
pierre à des genres extrêmement capables
qui ont beaucoup de métier beaucoup de
bonne volonté et qui pour des raisons
diverses et en particulier politiques
ont été un peu débordé à certains
moments
les raisons politiques sont liées à la
souveraineté que les macédoniens entend
garder sur leur sol jamais ils n'ont
plié devant le hcr la france elle a
annoncé hier qu'elle acceptait
d'accueillir des réfugiés et leur
propose un visa de long séjour
sinon plus de papier le document rempli
par l'eau et c'est suffire à préserver
les réfugiés ça consiste d'abord à faire
en sorte qu'ils puissent revenir dans le
pays le plus vite possible
supposer qu'un règlement politique de la
question du kosovo les semaines qui
viennent il
qu'il puisse revenir chez eux c'est ce
qu'ils souhaitent maintenant si certains
d'entre eux souhaitent s'établir pour un
certain temps ailleurs gloire pouvoir le
faire la position de la france est
ambigu car tout en conservant sa ligne
politique du maintien des réfugiés dans
la région
elle propose en même temps d'en
accueillir sur son sol un accueil
frileux car concrètement ici seuls 300 à
400 places sont proposées et pour
l'instant rien n'a été organisée pour le
départ
nous évoquions il ya quelques instants
le bombardements par les avions de
l'otan d'un convoi de réfugiés c'était
une information de source serbe des
images viennent de nous parvenir elles
sont été tourné par l' agence ap tn sous
contrôle serbe
elle montre les conséquences dramatiques
de ces bombardements de l'aviation
l'otan sur un convoi de réfugiés ce
break soit un convoi avec des tracteurs
un peu comme les images nous venons de
voir le bilan fourni par les autorités
servent encore une fois serait de 75
morts et de dizaines de blessés cette
seconde barre de man ray lieu dans
l'ouest du kosovo
non loin des lieux où se trouvaient nos
envoyés spéciaux hier le maïs boucau le
racontait et ses cohortes de me réfugier
utilisent tous les moyens pour se
déplacer ils auraient été les victimes
du bombardement de l'otan dans courant
de cette journée ces images ont été
fournies je le répète encore par l'
agence ap tm sous contrôle serbe 75
morts et sans doute des dizaines de
blessés à propos de l'engagement
français aux côtés des autres pays
membres de l'otan et profitant de la
campagne électorale pour les élections
européennes
le candidat alain krivine ont accompagné
cette fois d'arlette laguiller et est
aujourd'hui à nanterre marquant très
vivement son opposition frappe en serbie
reportage alban nicosie marcel martin
voilà trente ans alain krivine prêche
est ici même la révolution et s'était
trouvé un ennemi symbolique
l'impérialisme américain aujourd'hui sur
le kosovo le discours n'est finalement
pas si éloigné quand il fustigera de
calmants l'intervention de l'otan cette
guerre est absurde
elle est absurde et les dramatiques elle
est honteuse elle est inefficace elle
est il efficace
milosevic paradoxalement renforcé par
l'otan la salle réagit conteste alain
krivine sourit on est bien dans la
tradition de l'extrême gauche alors
alain krivine se justifie explique que
l'otan incarnant fait surtout la
politique étrangère des états unis
est ce qu'aujourd'hui les américains
proposent des mois pas d'ailleurs
d'aller bombarder tel aviv
parce qu on oublie qu'il ya deux
millions de palestiniens qui depuis 40
ans vivent dans des camps sont jamais
rentrés chez eux et tout le monde s'en
fout il ne dira rien en revanche sur les
moyens de faire coexister en paix serbes
et kosovars à la différence du parti
communiste l'extrême gauche n'est pas
tenu à la solidarité gouvernementale
alors alain krivine et arlette laguiller
se verrait bien rassemblés les opposants
au conflit
si celui-ci perdurait pendant la
campagne militaire au kosovo la campagne
électorale continue
voilà pour le dossier d'actualité au
kosovo le juge d'instruction chargé du
dossier des emplois présumés fictifs du
rpr à la ville de paris a reçu le
résultat de l'enquêté menée par des
policiers sur ces différents emplois
pendant la période 90-95 est un rapport
de synthèse établie le 25 mars dernier
par un commandant de police
la liste des salaires présumés fictifs
est estimé à 40 millions de francs selon
les révélations publiées par le canard
enchaîné explication olivier caroff 40
millions de francs charges comprises
c'est l'argent économisé par le rpr dans
les années 90 grâce à un système présumé
d'emplois fictifs
le calcul a été fait par la police
judiciaire employés après employés à
tous les niveaux de la hiérarchie du
parti gaulliste des dix mille francs
mensuels versés à une secrétaire au
salaire du bras droit d'alain juppé
patrick stefanini la paye d'une
quarantaine de permanents du rpr était
ainsi pris en charge par la ville de
paris ou par des entreprises privées
le rapport rendu public par le canard
enchaîné veine on sen systèmes
délictueux opéré avec l'aval de ses
instances dirigeantes
alain juppé l'un des anciens présidents
du parti a été mise en examen dans cette
affaire
son prédécesseur au rpr jacques chirac a
lui était déclarée intouchable par la
justice mais un militant écologiste a
décidé de revenir à la charge
un homme qui a porté plainte dans cette
affaire et qui demandent l'audition de
jacques chirac comme témoin si nous nous
portons nos efforts si je peux dire sur
la toile président de la république sait
que de toute façon il était directement
impliqué là dedans
clairement c'est votre conviction c'est
ma conviction est le rapport de police
est ce qu'il dit dans 15 heures
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs le stipule le
très nettement plus que ce rapport de
police c'est l'initiative de pierre
alain brossault qui pourrait à nouveau
obligé la justice à se prononcer sur le
cas de jacques chirac il faut ajouter
que l'ancien directeur du personnel de
la ville de paris monsieur georges
semmar a été condamné pour complicité de
diffamation envers monsieur jean tiberi
le maire de paris pour lui avoir imputé
la création d'emplois fictifs
condamnation de monsieur qu'est mort par
le tribunal correctionnel de paris à 20
mille francs d'amendé au tunnel de
fréjus la nouvelle réglementation mise
en place par le ministre des transports
qui impose une vitesse limitée une
réduction du nombre de véhicules poids
lourds chaque heure provoqué aujourd'hui
un gigantesque embouteillage
cette nouvelle réglementation a été
décidée après le drame de l'incendié du
tunnel du mont blanc qui a fait au moins
41 morts reportage au tunnel de fréjus
virginie fichet olivier jacquin au plus
fort de la journée quelques 400 semi
remorques s'aligner patiemment sur 5 km
devant le péage de saint michel de
maurienne
mais combien de temps que j'attendais a
fait une heure
une heure pour faire 22 km
ça va vraiment eu sans doute silence a
duré longtemps
arrêt obligatoire et attente forcée car
c'est ici à 20 kilomètres du tunnel du
fréjus que commence l'application des
consignes gouvernementales nous faire
attendre trente secondes pour réguler
pour la désormais le tunnel du fréjus ne
doit pas absorber plus de 140 camions
par heure le péage fait donc office de
filtre et l'autoroute a43 a été
transformé en véritable aire de stockage
les deux axes pour arriver aux twins et
d'une part l'autre l'autre par la
nationale 6 réguler sur l'autoroute
c'est relativement simple grâce aux
barrières de péage et sur la nationale 6
ans ne savait pas faire donc la décision
qui a été prise c'est de rabattre tout
le trafic poids lourds sur l'autoroute
c'est le camion prises et d'autoroutes
aujourd'hui est contraint d'emprunter la
nationale les transports de marchandises
dangereuses
d'abord bloqué au pied de la rampe
d'accès au tunnel ils sont ensuite
systématiquement exporté dans leur
traversée au fur et à mesure on va dire
de l'écoulement du trafic qu'on est
capable de faire c'est à dire environ
sept camions donc que sous escorte on va
dire toutes les 30 minutes ont fait
monter donc des escortes à partir
d'ottawa
donc on a des norias qui est quasi
cinématiques pendant toute la journée au
lieu de douze mille l'an dernier plus de
50000 poids lourds seront ainsi convoyé
cette année de chaque côté du tunnel
on se dit prêt à gérer ces nouvelles
contraintes pendant plusieurs mois
encore et puis à ce sujet je dois une
mise au point concernant un reportage
diffusé hier dans cette édition sur le
rapport d' enquête après la catastrophe
du tunnel du mont blanc nous évoquions
un rapport qui aurait été remis au
préfet monsieur breuil
il convient de préciser que ce rapport
était une demande de financement et que
depuis la prise de fonctions de monsieur
breuil en haute savoie
la préfecture n'a reçu aucune mise en
garde au sujet du tunnel du mont blanc
c'est ce qu'affirme la préfecture une
filiale du groupe sidérurgique français
la sollac prévoit 8 140 suppressions
d'emplois directs cette année cela qu
emploie actuellement 18 personnes sur 13
sites c'est à dunkerque que les
suppressions d'emploi seraient les plus
importantes d'ici 2003 les contribuables
français qui remplissent des
déclarations d'impôt pourrait voir
supprimer cette formalité que d'aucuns
apprécié comme une corvée ce sont les
services du fisc eux-mêmes qui
remplirait alors les déclarations
à condition bien sûr que celle ci soit à
simple explication jean-paul chapelle la
déclaration de revenus sera bientôt très
très simplifiées le fisc va remplir lui
même la feuille du contribuer
abl à partir des renseignements fournis
par l'employeur la sécurité sociale et
même la banque pour tous les revenus de
capitaux mobiliers l'informatique
permettait déjà de recouper de contrôler
toutes les données désormais les
ordinateurs du trésor feront le travail
jusqu'au bout
il suffira alors de signer cette
déclaration expresse avant de la
renvoyer
ce sera le cas pour 10 millions de
contribuables un foyer sur trois ils
n'auront rien à modifier ou à rajouter
les autres ceux qui sont dans une
situation fiscale plus complexes
rajouteront eux mêmes les éléments
particuliers en cas d'erreur ou de
contestation on pourra rayer les
chiffres préinscrits que les remplacer
par sa propre déclaration
autre innovation pour faciliter la vie
du contribuable
il aura à partir de 2001 un seul
interlocuteur un correspondant fiscal
unique ou leur enseigner ou l'aider dans
ses démarches
le ministère de l'économie veut ainsi
montrer que son administration ses se
moderniser pour rendre un meilleur
service aux usagers
une façon aussi de consoler le
contribuable à qui on ne promet aucune
baisse d'impôt sur le revenu
la fédération française de rugby club
procède chaque année à cette période et
une évaluation du budget annuel moyen de
l'automobiliste français
la dernière publication date fait état
d'une baisse du coût soude les 40000
francs par an quand même pour ça c'est
la bonne nouvelle la mauvaise c'est que
les détenteurs d'une automobile en
france sont beaucoup plus taxé que leurs
homologues européens commentaires luc
bizien et alain poirier
voici la voiture de référence retenue
pour le calcul du budget de
l'automobiliste 98 soit la plus vendue
du marché la clio 5 chevaux
son propriétaire a dépensé en moyenne 38
1704 francs sur l'année soit 3200 25
francs par mois soit encore 106 francs
par jour en fait l'achat de la voiture
est allée sur quatre ans pèse évidemment
le plus lourd dans le budget viennent
ensuite les frais liés au stationnement
du véhicule suivi de près par le
carburant et l'entretien
mais il existe des différences d'une
région à l'autre le budget de
l'automobiliste de l'île de france ou de
la région provence alpes côte d'azur par
exemple dépasse d'environ 10000 francs
celui du poitou de la bourgogne et de la
franche comté
l'explication est simple le
stationnement en milieu urbain coûte
beaucoup plus cher qu'en milieu
rural d'autre part la pression fiscale
s'accroît de toute façon pour tous
l'achat est taxé à 23% soit un peu plus
que la tva en revanche l'usagé de la
voiture lui est taxé à près de 100%
l'état encourage donc l'acquisition mais
décourage l'utilisation de la voiture
que l'état ne peut pas se passer d'étape
mais il est quand même dommage que
l'étal l'état ne rend pas à
l'automobiliste les formes que
l'automobiliste lui donne c'est à dire
près de 338 milliards cette année en
taxes pour utiliser le comparer à ses
deux proches voisins européens l'anglais
et l'allemand le français lui il reste
le plus taxé alors qu'il possède la
voiture la plus petite du sport du
cyclisme avec la 63e édition de la
flèche wallonne on attendait jalabert
est le premier arrivé à lui en belgique
fut l'italien michele bartoli de
l'équipe mapei équipe eut réussi en ce
moment en tout cas sur le plan cyclistes
et sportif demain clôture du festival
banlieues bleues à aubervilliers avec
une grande soirée hommage et archie
shepp amont même titre que john coltrane
et duke ellington archie shepp est une
référence du jazz pourtant peu
d'amateurs savent que ce musicien a
choisi de vivre en france à paris ratti
chap était allé disant trahi par son
ancienne maison de disques américaine et
ils continuent à user pourtant de son
saxophone pourrait écrire un peu de
l'histoire du jazz
reportage portrait de michel mompontet
yanncik m
tout simplement parce qu'il est l'homme
des inaccessible héros de ma discothèque
jamais je n'aurais imaginé le croiser un
jour sur un trottoir de paris par caen
faire ses courses comme n'importe quel
français anonyme
et derrière ce sourire de vieux sage qui
devinerait un des plus grands artistes
américains du siècle un artiste qui se
moquent bien aujourd'hui de sa gloire
une gloire fait pour les dictionnaires
quand une fois mort on le reconnaîtra
peut être enfin pour ce qui est mais lui
qui a tout connu et croiser tout le
monde réapprend désormais l'anonymat
dans sa nouvelle ville paris dans un
immeuble où il est inconnu
comment il s'appelle votre locataire
caméra et la concierge espagnol encore
besoin de ses antisèches pour se
rappeler du nom de cet illustre inconnu
du locataire du sixième chef archi chef
chanteur compositeur saxophoniste trahi
par son ex maison de disques fatigué
d'amérique et vit désormais dans ce
somptueux 10 mètres carrés quelque part
à paname
vous avez pas été en norvège en
angleterre l'allemagne ou pourquoi la
france choisit et elle est là aussi
cette mythique boîte le saxophone comme
un corbillard qui l'attend comme une
promesse de fait selon l'humeur du jour
je peux pas le tout est comme avant
on vous laisse ici les voisins vous avez
des problèmes ça oui je vais servir
quand je mentionne mais seulement des
touristes
ça ça me c'est elle a souhaité que
peut-être par les a vraiment changé
c'était pas la ville est connue et moi
qui paierez pour être le voisin de
monsieur cheikh pour pouvoir lui dire au
travers de la cloison
vas-y archi joue joue encore
je
avant de refermer ce journal nous allons
revenir sur l'actualité au kosovo tout
d'abord concernant les bombardements de
l'aviation de l'otan
il semble que l'aviation de l'otan et
touché un convoi de réfugiés dans
l'ouest du kosovo
il y aurait au moins 75 morts de sources
serbes n'ont confirmé à bruxelles du
côté de l'otan rappelle avec françois
cornet est bien à 20h35 toutefois l'otan
vient de confirmer qu'un bombardier qui
attaquait une route au kosovo a pu
toucher ce convoi de réfugiés un
bombardement qui a fait d'après les
sources serbes 64 victimes parmi
laquelle lesquels des femmes et des
enfants ainsi qu'une vingtaine de
blessés
ces images ont été tournées par une
agence britannique sous le contrôle des
autorités serbes
ces réfugiés étaient en majorité des
albanais qui regagnaient leurs foyers au
kosovo après avoir fui des zones de
combat bien sûr belgrade accueille ce
soir l'otan de crimes contre l'humanité
pourquoi cette méprise
l'otan poursuit ses investigations en
dépouillant les enregistrements vidéo
des appareils qui viennent de se poser
cet après midi l'état major avait
annoncé que les bombardiers devait
attaqué des convois militaires
et puis sur le plan de l'action
diplomatique concernant ce conflit au
kosovo il y avait une réunion du conseil
européen
aujourd'hui à bruxelles le conseil
européen avait demandé à monsieur kofi
annan le secrétaire général de l'onu de
venir à bruxelles pour assister à cette
réunion qu'elle participe et monsieur
jacques chirac et monsieur chirac
après avoir travaillé avec ses collègues
européens fait part d'une proposition
tandis qu'il y avait un plan de paix
allemand une proposition de créer une
force intérimaire internationale
européenne au kosovo propos de monsieur
chirac
nous avons proposé que l'union
européenne soit chargée par le conseil
de sécurité d'assumer cette
administration provisoire
nous avons indiqué que
l'union européenne devaient être
disponibles disposé à assumer cette
charge
naturellement nous ne sommes pas encore
là
chacun le comprend mais le jour où
l'accord politique interviendra il
faudra être prêt et puis en algérie
c'est l'autre titres de l'actualité de
cette journée six candidats sur cette
élection présidentielle dont le scrutin
devait avoir lieu demain se retire de la
compétition en dénonçant des fraudes il
reste donc comme seul candidat monsieur
bouteflika intervention du président
algérien ben yamin zeroual dans quelques
minutes à la télévision algérienne dans
un instant de la météo avec isabelle
martinet à 21h05
l'instit avec gérard klein et puis ça se
discute avec jean luc delarue
et puis à une heure du matin le dernier
journal qu'il sera présentée par ference
du brassus du cercle de philippe lefait
qui s'intéressera au festival du livre
et du vin de saumur autour du thème de
l'oeuvre de balzac
demain 7 50 dans les 4 vérités françoise
de votes recevra le député vert noël
mamère à 13h votre vraie rachid arhab à
demain 20h bonsoir merci